when you look at this right what does it
actually tell you you've got this x
equals one two three four
can someone tell me what's the what's
the meaning of that Max is going to kick
us off what do you think that indicates
for us yeah fantastic see this X here
we're going to replace it with one two
three or four depending on now that's
the next question
depending on what remember the previous
question we looked at what are the
different options it's two three four
and five
yeah in this case it's saying these are
the only possible X values you're going
to get the other any other values like x
equals five that kind of thing they have
a probability of zero they're never
going to happen
so far so good all right look at the
table underneath complete the tempo
values for this probability distribution
as Max suggested when x equals 1 what's
the probability of that particular score
happening when I sausage in one one
tenth very good when x equals to the
probability Billy 2/10 and then 3/10 and
then for 10 so that's not it's not super
complicated
conveniently one tenths plus two tenths
plus three times two is four tenths
what is it add up to it adds up to one
so we've got everything ok so far so
good
now I want you to read this next part
super carefully formula okay papi it
says hence calculate the mean of the
distribution calculate the mean I'm just
going to write that down
can I ask you guys how do we normally
calculate the mean if I wanted to
calculate the mean height of this group
of people you guys right what would I do
yeah go ahead
add the scores add however tall each
single one of you is and then I'll
divide by in this case sixteen sixteen
people make sense add them all up then
divide okay
can anyone see why this is kind of a
teeny bit of a problem looking at how do
I try and do that with this for example
how many people scored one in this
situation a tenth how many of them is
that I don't actually know right like
this doesn't tell you anything about how
large the group is this could be sixteen
people it could be sixteen hundred
people okay now what that means is if
just imagine with me right imagine we
had what's the simplest the smallest
number of people that you can imagine
fitting this think about it you got a
probability of 1/10 2/10 to ten people
right if you had ten people that's a
smallest group of people that could fit
this right so all of those 10 people how
many go to score of one one of them how
many of the Ottomans got a score of two
two of them and then three okay and you
get the idea so here's our ten people
right how would I calculate the mean of
that group I thought you told me before
what am I going to do Adam all that add
it all up so I'm gonna go add add add
etc and then I'm gonna divide by in this
case ya the amount of people which is
ten okay now I want you to look closely
at the previous page when you calculate
an expected value go back and have a
look at that right when you calculate
expected value look at your first line
of working not the answer look at your
first line of working did you notice
this is exactly what you're doing you
see that right like that over ten do you
know you've got decimals in your thing
like what were they 0.1 0.2 etc that's
one out of ten and two out of ten and
three or ten and so on right so when you
add all of them up for expected value
the mean is actually what you're
calculating okay so can I ask you where
you've written down mean equals I'd like
you to write the mean equals the
expected value they are not the same
thing but in this context they are the
way we calculate this same value
can you go ahead and work out with the
expected values go ahead and calculate
it for this distribution okay I know
there's at least one but who else has an
answer yep
you get three fantastic okay now because
I think you're starting to get into the
rhythm of this I'm just going to show
you how we go from here to the next
thing what's the next thing they asked
for calculate is standard deviation so
there's not a straight line from
expected value to standard deviation
what's the thing we've got to work out
in between variance very good once we've
got variance we then take the square
root and we'll get the standard
deviation so this is what it's going to
look like okay whoops wrong one sorry
that's the next page there is our
expected value which you guys told me
was three thumbs up and then here is us
calculating the variance and then taking
the square root okay now what I want you
to do is I imagine rehearsing through
with me calculating the expected value
for this particular question so what I
want you to do is you go blah blah blah
you get zero point nine five so just
type in zero point nine five and then
hit equals okay so this is what your
calculator is showing you after you've
put all of this in yeah so far so good
okay pay close attention top left-hand
corner press the shift button and then
the button you're looking for after
shift is one of the small gray buttons
on the bottom left-hand corner it says
our CL which then
to recall but above that it says store
very good so when you press that store
you can now choose any letter that you
like for this to be assigned to you I
don't know what your calculators have
you have an E and I'm like it's written
in red you've got an e I use Aoife
expected value right so I'm going to put
that in and if you did it right your
calculator will say this sorry it'll say
answer and then there will be an arrow
and then whatever letter you chose and I
chose E okay now the reason why this is
helpful is you would not believe how
many people get this right and they know
exactly how to do this and guess where
it goes wrong just when they're pressing
buttons because it's just so many things
to press right so yeah did you ask I
will yeah absolutely
you've got zero point nine five or
whatever the answer is in the display it
has to be in the display so I've got
zero point nine five there in the bottom
right hand corner so don't clear it
shift store and then press any of these
little buttons that has a letter over
the top so I've got ABCDE F XY m and you
can choose whichever you want
I chose II which is above cause is that
have you got a above cause on your
calculator yep depends on just yeah do
you choose that you've got slightly some
people have they don't have NF I don't
know why different models something like
that no so once you press shift store
just press the letter straightaway
and then when you want to use that
letter if this is what you're asking if
for example see this part here I'm gonna
use the expected value yeah in my
calculator display I'm gonna write 0.2
bracket negative 1 minus then to get
back to my e I say alpha e and that's
how I get it okay alpha and then you can
see the letter appear in your screen ok
so just make sure whatever it connect to
value get you just use the same one over
and over again make sense they tell you
for a particular probability
distribution it's got this expected
value and then if you read the table
carefully then this is what you would do
if you wanted to calculate the expected
value the real question the actual
question they're asking is what's a
what's B okay that's the question right
now look
carefully this because it looks kind of
like mmm I'm used to just pumping the
values in getting my calculator and then
it giving me the expected value but
they're quick they're posing this
question in Reverse they've given you
the expected value it's another thing
they want to work out so the first thing
you can say is this thing here I already
know what it's supposed to equal to so
this is an equation which has an A and
AB in you can simplify out and you'll
have something that you can do which
will relate and be together but it's not
enough to solve you've got one equation
and two unknowns you need an equation
for every single unknown so there's
another equation we need to form that
connects a and B have a look at the way
that I've written it right see my zero
point for my zero point one this zero
point one what are they what are they
represent there they're going to be
probabilities aren't they when you're
working out expected value like twos not
a probability yeah it's one of the
discrete random variables the zero point
four is the probability so a and B are
also probabilities right when you get
the whole distribution what are the
probabilities supposed to add up to one
right so if I take the zero point four
and the zero point one and the a and the
other zero point one and the B when I
add them all up I should get a full one
now when you've got two equations
together and they're working at the same
time what do we call that simultaneous
equations you know exactly how to do
this
it's just dressed up in some statistics
language okay